[Music]
Charlie Sheen once made headlines for
claiming he had tiger blood but now you
rarely hear about him so what happened
from sitcom star to bunking on his
parents sofa Sheen's very public
downfall was several years in the making
Charlie Sheen's addictions took a huge
toll in his career his drug and alcohol
abuse led to a number of unsettling
incidents over the years including a
1990 freak accident that resulted in his
then fiance Kelly Preston getting shot
in the arm he also seemed to struggle
with sex and addiction you've been
called a sex addict yeah you think you
are I'm sure in 1995 Sheen admitted to
spending approximately $50,000 on sex
workers through Hollywood Madam Heidi
fce furthermore in divorce papers filed
by his ex-wife Denise Richards in 2006
she hinted that Sheen had a porn
addiction in the papers Richard said she
discovered he had access disturbing porn
websites that featured very young women
who looked underage moreover John CER
Sheen's co-star on 2 and a Half Men
revealed in his 2015 Memoir that he once
helped Sheen hide a bag filled with porn
from Richards Sheen's substance abuse
issues also reportedly got worse during
his divorce with Richards CER told
Entertainment Weekly in 2020 at first he
could handle it and he was still
incredibly professional but you could
just see that stuff was wearing on him 2
and a Half Men went on Hiatus in 2011 so
Sheen could address his problems however
he refused to go to rehab and let go of
his sobriety coach later that year he
was fired from the show with h up saying
he was hurting himself by engaging in
dangerously self-destructive Behavior
throughout his career scandals and legal
issues seem to follow Sheen wherever he
went he was arrested for domestic
violence in 2009 sued for allegedly
choking and threatening to kill an adult
film star in 2010 and sued for assault
and sexual battery in 2014 in 2020 Cory
Feldman also accused Sheen of sexually
assaulting Corey Haim while making the
movie Lucas in 1986 Sheen was 19 and
Haim was 13 when they worked together on
the film Feldman made the claim in his
documentary my truth the rape of two
quaries Sheen was also sued by two of
his exes for not telling them he had HIV
before they had unprotected sex the
first incident happened in 2015 when his
former fiance scottin Ross claimed they
had sex at least five times before she
discovered he was HIV positive in
addition she made claims of assault
battery emotional distress and false
imprisonment against him alleging that
he even put an unloaded gun into her
head and pulled the trigger the second
incident happened in 2017 when one of
his ex-girlfriends who chose to stay
Anonymous accused Sheen of exposing her
to HIV the woman also claimed that Sheen
dissuaded her from taking medicine to
prevent transmission of the virus
Sheen's ex-girlfriend Brie olssen also
spoke out against him to Inside Edition
for similar reasons in 2015 but didn't
press charges he is a
monster in 2016 Sheen told Dr o he had
bipolar disorder and was not taking any
medication for it Sheen's struggles with
mental health and addiction led to a
bizarre public breakdown in 2011 that
his image never fully recovered from
during a 2011 interview with 2020 Sheen
made this strange claim I I I am on a
drug it's called Charlie Sheen um it uh
it's not available CU if you try it once
you will die Sheen then went on the
Today's Show and said I'm tired of
pretending I'm not special I'm tired of
pretending I'm not a total rock star
from Mars he also wrote a statement
about being booted from 2 and 1 Half Men
telling TMZ this is very good news they
continue to be in breach like so many
whales it is a big day of gladness at
the sober Valley Lodge because now I can
take all of the bazillions and I never
have to put on those silly shirts for as
long as this warlock exists in the
terrestrial dimension on top of all that
he said that he had tiger blood and
Adonis DNA which had become some of his
most memorable quotes I'm by winning
I win here and I win there now what
however in 2021 Sheen told Yahoo
entertainment that he now regrets his
behavior he told the outlet I think the
growth for me post meltdown has to start
with absolute ownership of my role in
all of it and it was desperately
Juvenile and I probably should have
begged for my job back Sheen's struggle
with addiction wasn't the only reason he
was kicked off Two and a Half Men after
the show went on Hiatus in 2011 so he
could go to rehab he went on several tie
raids against the Show's co-creator and
producer Chuck Lori during an interview
with Alex Jones he called Lori a clown
and a charlatan he followed that up with
an interview with TMZ saying he's a
stupid stupid little man and a punk that
I never want to be like that's me being
polite during these interviews he only
referred to Lori as Heim LaVine because
Lori was born Charles LaVine and Heim
would be the Hebrew version of his name
TV Executives at Warner Brothers and CBS
found this to be anti-Semitic and it was
around this time that they fired Sheen
from the series Sheen was definitely not
happy about that and responded with this
angry statement given to TMZ what does
this say about Heim LaVine Chuck Lori
after he tried to use his words to judge
an attempt to degrade me I fire back
once and this contaminated little maggot
can't handle my power and can't handle
the truth clearly I have defeated this
earthworm with my words Landing rolls
after such a messy public Feud and
meltdown was no easy task for char Sheen
as a result he was unable to continue
paying child support for four of his
five kids in 2019 Richards filed a
lawsuit against him for child support
during which he explained he had been
blacklisted by the entertainment
industry according to the Daily Mail the
outlet also reported that Sheen said he
was in a dire financial crisis and had
less than $10 million in the bank for
years Sheen only made a handful of short
TV appearances then in 2020 he joined
Cameo a service that allows fans to
purchase personalized video messages
from celebrities the former 2 and A2 men
star set his rate at $300 per video that
same year he sold his Mansion for $6.6
million which was significantly less
than the asking price he then moved in
with his elderly mother and father in
2021 A source told okay that Sheen was
broke and only gets calls to appear in
commercials we can save you hundreds a
month with single care yes we can CC pu
the clash between Sheen and Lori
wouldn't be the actor's last public Feud
while Sheen was working with Selma Blair
on the series Anger Management in 2013
she complained to Executives about
Sheen's bad work ethic behind his back
when he found out he was so Furious that
he told producers to fire blur
immediately or he'd leave the show
according to the Hollywood Reporter
Sheen went off on Blair over text
insulting her and telling her she was
dismissed from the series Blair was
noticeably absent from the set the
following Monday then the next day
Lionsgate television released a
statement saying we're confirming that
Selma Blair will not not be returning to
anger management and we wish her the
very best they plan to write her out of
the show and replace her with the new
female role for the rest of the
production in 2019 Charlie Sheen was
supposed to be seen on season 28 of
Dancing With the Stars but that never
ended up happening a week before the
premiere he had a sudden change of heart
and walked away Sheen explained to US
Weekly I was very flattered by ABC and
their offer but at the end of the day I
have two left feet and I just can't
dance the actor's appearance on the show
was part of a larger deal at ABC so when
he backed out of the project the bigger
deal was scrapped his publicist Jeff
Ballard confirmed this with US Weekly
saying that the network made a generous
offer for a new series starring Sheen
but it was contingent upon Him appearing
on the popular dance competition show
Sheen was replaced by former
professional football player Ray Lewis
the incident dealt another damaging blow
to Sheen's career showing Executives
that he still hadn't gotten his act
together even though it been years since
the 2 and a Half Men debacle so what's
the next for for Charlie she um well
gosh I I still act many stars have made
comebacks after behaving in scandalous
erratic ways could Charlie Sheen have
the next big comeback possibly but he'd
have some big hurdles to overcome due to
his long history of substance abuse and
behavioral problems James Robinson the
CEO of Morgan Creek Productions told TMZ
in 2011 that he was reluctant to hire
Sheen For an upcoming film saying I'm
not going to risk putting Charlie in the
movie if he continues Messing up if
Charlie doesn't straighten up I
unfortunately can't put him in the movie
he also recalled his experience working
with Lindsay Lohan back in her wild days
adding when an actor doesn't show up for
work you can lose half a million dollars
a day paying the 250 other people there
for the shoot and the cost for the set
if a production company was considering
hiring Sheen they would likely want to
insure him so they wouldn't lose money
if he didn't show up for work according
to a 2011 article in The Hollywood
Reporter sometimes the stars' insurance
plans include High deductible ranging
from $25,000 to
$250,000 the cost of ensuring an actor
gets lower as they complete jobs without
any incidents so at this point in time
things aren't looking great for
Sheen if you or anyone you know needs
help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact Samson's National he
line at 1800 662 help
[Music]